NARRATOR (VOICEOVER): For
America have fled their
homes to seek a better
life in the United States.
Between 1980 and
2013, the population
of people in the US
born in Central America
grew from just around 300,000
to over three million.
The majority came from a region
known as the Northern Triangle,
which includes the
nations of Guatemala,
El Salvador, and Honduras.
During this time,
these nations suffered
from economic and political
instability, corruption,
crime, poverty, and violence.
One of the major causes of
such strife, the Cold War.
From 1947 through 1991, the
period now known as the Cold
War, the US adopted
interventionist
foreign policies in an effort
to stop the spread of communism.
These policies led to the
Korean War and the Vietnam War.
They also led to US
intervention in Central America.
The US provided funding,
arms, and military training
to nations and groups fighting
communism like Guatemala.
After World War
II, Guatemala was
one of the few Latin
American countries
that operated as a democracy.
In 1951, Guatemala
democratically
elected Jacobo Arbenz,
who aimed to fight
poverty and inequality
by redistributing
property more fairly.
At the time, 75% of the arable
land was controlled by only 2%
of the population.
One of the largest landowners
was an American corporation
known as the United
Fruit Company
with about 600,000
acres of property.
Arbenz's policies would
reduce their power and profit.
So the US declared these
progressive land reforms,
as well as Arbenz's legalization
of the Communist Party,
as a threat to democracy.
In 1954, the CIA aided
in a military overthrow
of the Arbenz government,
leading to a civil war in 1960.
The war would go
on for 36 years.
A series of military
regimes supported
by the US employed death
squads, utilized torture,
and massacred Mayan villages.
Documents declassified
in the 1990s
revealed the CIA knew about
it, but did nothing to stop it.
In the end, approximately
200,000 people
were killed or disappeared.
The Civil War ended in 1996,
but the economic, societal, and
personal damage
would last decades,
prompting many to flee the
instability and violence
for the United States.
Guatemala's neighbor,
El Salvador,
suffered a similar fate.
In the 1980s, El Salvador
became embroiled in a civil war,
pitting the right wing
military government
against Marxist guerrillas.
The United States sided
with the government,
sending billions
of dollars in aid
as well as military advisors
to help the Salvadoran military
fight the war.
The war, like that in
Guatemala, was brutal.
In early 1980,
archbishop Oscar Romero,
the leader of the Catholic
church in El Salvador,
wrote a letter to then US
President Jimmy Carter, begging
him to stop funding the
Salvadoran military,
which had been terrorizing
the Salvadoran people.
On March 24th, 1980, one month
after sending the letter,
Romero was assassinated
while celebrating mass.
The killer had been hired by
right wing military officers.
More than 75,000 Salvadorans
were killed in the conflict.
Students and other
revolutionaries were shot.
Their bodies left on
roadsides as warnings.
Peasants trying to
flee were shot in mass.
In one massacre in
1981, as many as 1,200
civilian women, children,
and old men were massacred.
Once again, documents
declassified in the 1990s
showed the US was aware of
some of these atrocities,
but overlooked them for
common policy goals.
Through the 80s,
thousands of Salvadorans
fled for their safety.
From 1980 to 1990, the
Salvadoran immigrant population
in the United States increased
from 94,000 to 465,000.
The war was over by 1992,
and with its resolution
came a decline in immigration
to the US, but not an end.
A 1990s US policy deported
Salvadoran immigrants
with criminal records,
sending members of LA gangs
back to El Salvador,
where the gangs took hold
and became even more violent.
As of 2018, Salvadoran citizens
continue to seek asylum
in the US, as democratic
El Salvador still struggles
with the corruption, crime,
and gang violence set in motion
by the decades of conflict.
El Salvador's eastern
neighbor, Honduras,
also suffered in the American
War against communism.
Under the Reagan
administration, the US
sought to overthrow the
communist Sandinista government
in neighboring Nicaragua
by supporting the Contras,
a right wing
guerrilla rebel force.
The US temporarily
stationed several hundred
American soldiers in
Honduras and constructed
a number of joint Honduran
US military bases.
With the help of the
US, Honduras soon
became a militarized state,
creating the conditions
for political
repression, corruption,
and government violence.
The US also used its power
to push for deregulation
of the coffee trade,
benefiting US businesses,
but ultimately harming Honduras'
most vulnerable, its farmers
and its poor,
sending many fleeing
to the US for both economic
and safety reasons.
The rise in Central Americans
immigrating to the US,
like nearly every large influx
of immigrant groups in US
history, can be traced
back to instability
in their home country.
For the Irish in the
1840s, it was famine.
For the Jews in the early 1900s,
it was political oppression
and poverty.
For the Central Americans,
it's a complex story
of internal unrest partially
influenced by US intervention
during the Cold War.
But since the
founding of the US,
immigration has been a central
part of the American story,
and remained so until this day.